5 55 on your wednesday morning hey
there's a lane restriction shout out
here for the logandale
overton area you know we don't talk a
whole lot about the moapa valley so
want to make sure you drivers on state
highway 169
know about a daytime lane restriction
there it actually started on monday and
it's
supposed to last until next friday from
six in the morning until two in the
afternoon you're down to one lane at
lamar
avenue so that's the south end of
overton near the lost city museum
crews are digging out and replacing a
24-inch drainage pipe
got a flagging and a pilot car that will
be escorting one direction of traffic
through the work area while the other
direction waits for few minutes to get
their turn
uh indot nevada department of
transportation says they're going to
take the weekend off and no work on
memorial day you can review the lane
restriction and all of our stories about
traffic at 8newsnow.com click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please
put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy email me
traffic eight
at eight news now dot com